- Oh, this.
- You're like, my favorite guest so far.
It's like a BYOB, you bring your own beer?
- Right, this is actually an intervention,
so this works out.
I brought some shot glass,
- What do we have here?
- I hear you don't drink,
you don't drink beer?
- I drink, not usually, I like
a cider every now and then,
but I'm not, I'm a wine girl.
- You're from Texas and
you don't drink beer?
- I know, and here's the thing.
Doesn't this personality scream beer?
I exude like, she likes beer.
- I never thought that
when I first saw you.
I didn't go like, honey,
the beer girl's singing.
- Then you didn't see me properly.
My friends are more shocked than anyone.
- Have you ever done a beer commercial?
- No, I wouldn't, no.
- Would you do a beer commercial?
- How much am I being paid?
(audience laughs)
- A lot, a lot.
- I can drink beer for money.
- All right, this is a sparkling white.
- Okay, sparkling white.
- This is sparkling
white, it's from Spain.
- Love.
- Lovely.
- Love, Espana.
- Yup.
(giggles)
- So cultured.
- I don't know what
you're talking about, but,
yeah, we'll move on to the red in a bit
and then,
- Okay, okay, I like it.
- We'll get the first row,
- We should've had a
charcuterie board or something,
this could have been a whole,
like test tasting.
- This is,
Ellen never does this.
- No, we both love wine and food.
- We do.
- You are a foodie, right?
And wine?
- Probably too much.
- Yeah, is there a too much?
I don't know.
- No, It's not like
I would do it while I
was being interviewed.
- Not during the day before five.
- No, not in front of
a group of people, no.
Why would I do that?
I'm not, I don't have a problem.
- You're fine, I'm fine, everyone's fine.
(audience cheers)
I need to ask you though.
- Welcome back to Everyone's
Fine with Kelly Clarkson.
- That's my new book.
I need to ask you about this video.
Joel, could you, Joe, could
you roll this footage?
What's happening here?
- [Joel] All right, so
that, that's Thanksgiving.
That's a turkey, actually.
- Is that stuffing and the, wait,
that's a turkey cake?
- Okay, so this is, all right,
so there's a butcher shop here
called McCall's Meat and Fish,
and this amazing butcher named Megan
decided she would take an entire turkey
before it was cooked,
take all the meat off and the skin,
wrap it all back in the
skin with the stuffing
and then you put that in the oven
and you roast it for two and a half hours
and it comes out looking
like you cooked an alien.
But it is so good.
- Here's the thing,
it looks like something
I wanna eat right now,
so I'm into it.
- Yeah, did you bring one?
- Do you see how juicy that all looks
with the stuffing?
- Oh, it was very moist,
it was exactly how it, I got two of them.
We have 20 or 30 people
over for Thanksgiving.
- Oh my gosh you have a big family.
- Yeah no, and they just like free stuff.
- [Kelly] Moochers!
- They all come down from
Seattle and they stay with us,
10, like 11 people stay in the house,
and I cook and so does my wife
and then we have this huge dinner
and then I resent my
family for six months.
(laughing)
- All right, something else I know
that you love is your dog.
Your dog is always on Instagram.
Is it Beanbag?
- I don't have any dogs.
- You have a dog named Beanbag.
- Yes, I have three dogs.
So Beanbag the dog is,
- Wait, you have three dogs?
Why do you only, I only see the one.
- [Joel] Beanbag is
the, yeah that's, he's,
- [Kelly] He's crazy!
- See, I like how you're saying
aww and he's attacking me.
That's a normal morning.
He's a very excitable French bulldog.
If you could, there's no audio there,
which is really taking away from it.
We make a lot of silent
films, as you can see, and he,
- He's one of those morning kisses.
- Clearly tore my shirt off earlier, so,
yeah, he's insane and we
have these two other dogs
that get no press because they're,
well there he is again, that's how,
- Oh, they're more chill.
- That's Cowboy and Harry
and they're just miserable
because as all the time,
and then there he is, maniac.
- No, but you don't have
any cats though, right?
- No.
- I love cats, I'm allergic.
- My wife is horribly allergic.
But after, 'cause the Beanbag
and Cowboy have fur, not hair,
having been around them for
so long, she figured out
that she basically lost
her allergy to cats
and so now, I'm like.
- [Kelly] We have switched!
- Floodgates, I need to get some cats.
- Fine, bring out the cats.
- Oh, that is not what I mean, damnit.
- Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
- Oh my Lord!
- Oh my gosh,
they're adorable!
- Guys, these are actual cats.
- They're actually little kittens.
- This is,
- Y'all, all these kittens
are brothers and sisters
from the same litter.
The black and white ones are named
Spaetzle, Bucatini, and Ziti
and the orange ones are
Orzo, Ravioli and Bigolo.
Somebody likes pasta.
Bigoli, sorry.
- Right, and say, those are
all different types of sushi.
- They're going to hang out
with us though, for a bit
and by the end of the show,
maybe Joel will adopt one,
or he might do the smart thing
and wait for his wife's okay.
- Yes, I'm gonna adopt two
and then I'll get a divorce
because my wife will be like,
what the (beep) is going on?
- If anyone else wants
to adopt these kittens,
you can visit them
at Paw Works Adoption Center
in Camarillo, California.
- No, they're mine,
they're my cats.
- I mean, these kittens
are famous as well, okay?
As Supergirl the dog, they've
been on TV, you're gonna,
look at their faces.
- Look at their faces!
- My husband is so nervous right now.
I don't even care that I'm allergic,
I'll take a pill or something or a shot.
- You gotta push that cat across the table
like you're putting in a
bet, playing Texas Hold 'em,
and you're like, I'll raise you two cats.
- How much do you like cuddles?
Speaking of work though,
you're super talented.
You've got two films
at the Tribeca Film
Festival right now, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- One's called I Found a Kitty,
and the other one's called
Hey Look, A Squirrel!
- I'm Taking Home a Kitty.
- Yeah.
Yes, I do.
You know, 'cause it's at a film festival
so you'll all see it.
And won't be distracted at all
by the cat Olympics happening on,
let's just, you know what,
let's just let them go.
- Let's just let them,
- Just enjoy,
- Walk around.
- Enjoy yourselves, just go.
- Wait, they can't hurt themselves, right?
If they come off of the,
don't all cats land on your
feet or some, their feet?
Okay.
- [Joel] No, no, what
are you talking about?
- No, I've heard this.
If a cat falls or something,
they always land on their feet.
- So a cat falls, they land on their feet.
- Oh my god, it's on the back, I'm a mom.
I'm a mom, you gotta get it,
you gotta get it.
- I feel it.
It's gonna be fine, it's gonna,
- Come here.
- This is how they learn.
- Oh, I've gotta get
you, I've gotta get you.
- Anyway, I see you guys are
very excited about my films.
- The poor kitty.
- I mean, look at this!
Look how TV-ready they are.
- You just need some catnip on a cushion.
- Put an album cover right
here just like, this is,
look, have you ever seen.
- No, seriously though.
They're set up, they're set up.
- [Joel] This guy better fall in line.
All right, go over there.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're
crawl, you are a crawler.
- [Joel] That's good.
- Oh, you're going all the way around.
So about your films, what!
- [Joel] That guy.
- You're crazy, I don't
want you to die, man.
Okay, so about your films.
- I don't know.
- Becky and Happily.
- Becky and Happily, yes.
Becky is made by, it's a great,
it's me and a wonderful
actress named Lulu Wilson
and Kevin James.
(audience applauds)
It is definitely not a comedy
and then the other one's called Happily,
directed by a guy named BenDavid Grabinski
and it's me and a wonderful
actor named Kerry Bishe,
and Stephen Root, who you've seen on Barry
and a thousand other things on news radio,
and but no one's listening
to a thing I've said.
It doesn't matter, let's just,
- Because all the cats are here.
- Let's just move on to the
red and let's see what happens,
it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Take a sip.
Oh wait, that's mine.
- That's yours.
- Just kidding,
get rid of this.
- Oh my God.
- It's just like,
- You are hilarious!
- That's fine, that's fine.
- Okay, let's see the legs.
- So that's in April and I know
you'll all go to the film
festival, you gonna love it.
- So late.
- It's fine, it's fine, it's a cat.
- Wait, okay wait, Joel.
So Card Sharks, Card Sharks is back.
Do you like being a game host, is it fun?
- What is a game host?
- A game, you're hosting a game.
I think it's in the
definition is in the name.
- I think it's game show.
It's a game show host.
- A game show host.
- Yeah, we give away cats and,
- Please don't die.
- This is gonna go great.
Yeah, you can win, okay look, yes.
You can win a lot of money.
I can totally get you on the show.
- Yeah, okay.
- But if you think about it, Kelly,
no one's listening to a thing we have said
in the last few minutes.
- Well be sure to catch all the things
he's very excited about.
- Yeah, watch Card Sharks on ABC.
- Watch Card Sharks
this summer on ABC.
- Look at this, who cares!
- Also, Becky!
- Who cares, we're having fun.
- Also he has the films
Becky and Happily coming out
but we'll be right back
with Empire's Grace Byers,
also known as the villainous
ex wife of Lucious Lyon,
stay with us.
(upbeat music)